[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
let the count from Sesame Street I
wanted to think of our podcast as Dear
John and Hank by the way it's a podcast
full of comedy and talking about death
in which we answer your questions give
you DB suffice and big you all the
week's news from both Mars and AFC
Wimbledon and hey John you're my brother
how you doing I'm doing well
missy elliott has released a new single
beyonce is pregnant with twins the world
is full of hope i don't know what you're
talking about that things are dark
everything's great beyonce is having two
kids at once that's wonderful
i didn't know that that's really
exciting I like being able to break news
to you just wait till we get to the news
from AFC Wimbledon Hank unless you're a
hardcore follower of AFC Wimbledon you
probably haven't heard it I very very
likely have not heard it in fact I
haven't even heard the news from Mars
today I'm gonna have to try and pull
some out really last-minute here I
apologize for not being great at
podcasting that's alright we've come to
expect it no I'm just kidding you're way
better than I am
I am good I'm good either the other day
John I a car broke down on the side of
the road and I was helping them push it
out of the road and and the person was
like I'll be honest with you I just ran
out of gas and they were driving a Volvo
240 and I was like you know I've I've
run out of gas in that very car I
remember when you ran out of gas in that
very car because I remember mom coming
home after like picking you up and she
was in tears because of how gothy you
look with I mean was that it was that
why I would love to talk to her about it
now cuz she was so mad and I think maybe
maybe it's because I ran out of gas and
was being irresponsible possible but
maybe it was also cuz I had a bunch of
makeup on I don't know I don't know
would you like a poem for today Hank
yeah hit me with a poem John alright
it's appropriately short this is
actually a recommendation from Julian
longtime nerdfighter nerdfighter for 10
years now actually who recommended this
poem by Ayesha Syed it's called broken
English and it's by the daughter of a
refugee when my mother struggles to
spell
word in English I want to break the
entire language into little pieces so
the edges of these letters will stop
cutting her very good that's a nice
short poem it's pretty good
that is a short poem for the moments we
are living in life is hard and also has
good things let's try and have a little
bit peppier dear Hank and John today
than last time I feed right now we're
pretty low energy to quote the current
President of the United States low
energy exclamation point okay I found my
Mars news it's excellent excellent news
hooray
that's that thanks for preparing that's
uh let's do some questions John I've got
a really pressing one that I I really
want to hit it's from Jay and I want to
make sure we get to it so I'm going to
start with it Jay asks dear Hank and
John I'm very overwhelmed by the variety
of spoons for sale would you please rank
the top ten types of spoons every
aspiring gentleman should own Jay sure
yeah of course I don't actually have 10
types experience I only have six types
of spoons how many types of students do
you have how did you could you count did
you go cow-eyed well hey unlike some
people I'd prepare for this podcast it
depends on your definition of a type of
spoon I definitely have more than 10
spoons and and like they all are
different from one another in varying
ways some of them just have like
different manufacturing defects and
scratches from years of use but are but
are otherwise very similar and some are
in made of entirely different things in
very much different sizes so it's it's
hard what Hank do you just you don't
have like you know a system of cutlery
where it's all the same shape and
everything and you got all the cutlery
for your from your wedding like normal
people I think you did because I
actually bought you some of it oh yeah I
do for the like the main ones like my
knives and forks and spoons right but
what is a type like two spoons even if
they are from the same set they're going
to
be slightly different from each other
and so are they no they're not there's
you don't you know no he's asking about
types of spoons okay like how many types
of spoons do you need and the answer is
six
you need a regular spoon for everyday
spoon use you need the larger version of
the regular spoon for when you are
especially hungry especially with ice
cream if you need a soup spoon which is
more of a circular spoon Oh
Harry Potter's glasses kind of spoon now
strictly speaking you only need the
first two types of spoons but you can
get that that circular spoon a nice soup
spoon I actually find that eating soup
with a soup spoon is harder than eating
soup with a regular spoon but as you
know if you're gonna be particular about
it there is a soup spoon then you got
your fourth type of spoon which is your
your tea spoon you know for when you're
oh man you know just when your tea spoon
enables spoon for when you don't want to
count up like four teaspoons or whatever
is in a tablespoon and then the sixth
type of spoon you need is you need a
spoon for your children because children
for whatever reason cannot use any of
the previous five spoons they are super
hardcore about needing their own spoons
for their own little hands with a little
mini versions of spoons so you need six
spoons you know there's no need for ten
spoons that's that's it's incredible to
even think about yeah you've completely
you've completely left out an entire
category of spoons who dis booze used
for cooking you need a you need a ladle
which is a kind of like a type of spoon
you need a regular large serving spoon
possibly more than one large serving
spoon so that you can when you are like
having people at the table you can put
the serving spoon in so they don't have
to like very slowly one little spoonful
at a time put the food on their plate
and then you need a slotted spoon for I
don't know something there's a reason to
have a slotted spoon and then if you
have non-stick plates you also because
you are non-stick pans you can't use
those metal spoons in that because
you'll scrape off nonstick which is bad
so you need a wooden or plastic spoons
in addition to that so we're we're above
10 now you're right you do need 10
spoons if you count all the cooking
spoons so there you go Jay I mean people
have often said that this podcast is
completely useless and a waste of their
but now you know the ten spoons you need
to acquire to have a successful adult
life really I would say you could get by
with two spoons one large spoon for your
pots and serving and one regular spoon
for literally everything else although
it is nice to have a teaspoon and a
tablespoon because there's a lot of
baking it's hard to make cookies if you
don't if you can't tablespoon hey I have
a question it comes from Christine who
writes Dear John and Hank why does every
boy I kiss kiss like a fish opening and
closing his mouth while kissing me so
that I can't get my tongue in his mouth
have I learned it wrong
I know in movies they kiss like this but
when I was a teenager I read this book
about how to do stuff as a teen girl and
it said you should just let your tongue
play with their tongue how do boys learn
to kiss anyway if they don't have
teenage girl books or magazines note
this didn't happen with the only girl I
kissed making that the best kiss I've
ever had love from the land of
bitterballen
Christine I'm qualified to answer this
question but I do remember when I was
young that there was a lot of like quick
opening and closing of the mouth like a
struggling afraid fish and I do remember
thinking like this doesn't seem right
even though it is what I've seen on TV
but it seems wrong and I think in
retrospect it it probably was wrong is
it not just excitement it's just like I
know how to eat is it like eating I've
got it try eating on your on this
person's face experience with kissing is
that it's not very much like eating no
it's well I mean if it's like a smoothie
maybe it's like eating a smoothie Oh God
just that's that's what they should say
in the boy books okay boys just pretend
like you're like you're really enjoying
some blend it up beef stew that's what a
kiss is
do that oh I mean all I can say
Christine is that it's important to
communicate with your partner and maybe
be like hey I know that you think that
the best way to do this is to be a be a
fish out of water but my preferred way
is to
be like two little eels interacting with
each other
I don't know Christine I mean I guess I
I don't want to I don't we got to move
on gotta move on well I'll say different
people kiss different ways and it's not
it's not totally down to gender so you
you you you might end up finding
different boys kiss different ways even
if the ones you've kissed so far are a
certain way I've got a question from
Michelle and I really want to ask it
because this is gonna lead me to talk
about some stuff that I've been wanting
to talk about for a while dear Hank and
John the other day I began having a
crisis about the classification of belly
buttons do belly buttons count as scars
I mean they're basically closed holes
isn't that what a scar is do scars have
to be unique to a person and or be the
product of some sort of injury
please help solve my dilemma as it's
keeping me up at night best wishes
Michelle mostly I want to talk about
this question because I want to talk
about belly buttons because I have a
baby now and the belly button thing
happened and I didn't really understand
how belly buttons happened and wow wow
that's weird yeah how did belly buttons
happen
yeah well placental mammals are so
strange whoa whoa I did not understand
how belly buttons works John oh yeah no
anyone with a child can tell you that
belly buttons are definitely scars yeah
also yes also it's not so I just I
pictured that like you had the baby and
then they cut the cord and then they and
then like a like a relatively like
recent relatively like close to that
point moment they just pulled the cord
off or something but that's not what
happens they cut the cord close to the
belly button and then it just sits there
for like weeks this like weird
keratinous scab on the your child's
belly and you have to like work around
it and like it cut doesn't smell good
like it's no it's we it's like got a
real funky scent and and sometimes it
gets bad and then like it gets infected
and it smells really bad and you have to
take them
but that didn't happen and so they're
like they're like if it smells funky
that's okay but if it smells bad and I'm
like I don't know what's the difference
between funky and bad it smells pretty
bad but apparently if it smells bad you
know you know it smells bad but anyway
that doesn't seem right and then it
slowly starts to peel off it's like it's
like a fingernail
like it's like connective tissue that's
been dried out it is so frickin weird
it is weird and I love my son very much
and I like and like fine like it's
beautiful and like magic magical but
weird and yes it is a scar and it has
like out like a one-of-a-kind scab that
happens and I just wanted everybody to
know that because nobody told me before
Matt my I experienced it myself I'm okay
though John
I might seem like I'm not okay but I'm
okay seem to be processing some pretty
deep stuff right so I'm alright but also
just like all so here's the thing I get
how milk happened it's just like a it's
another way of sweating basically it's
like you sweat more with more oils and
proteins and stuff and like like like
the like by platypi platypuses that they
like instead of having nipples they just
have like areas of their body that sweat
milk and so I can could see that I can
see how that could evolve but like belly
buttons and placentas and like where how
that's that's real weird that that
happened at all and I understand why
it's way better like it's a way better
way to make a mammal then like like
marsupials are kind of like the
intermediate stage and I have I get why
placenta was better but man I I was hmm
I it made me it made me think harder
about placental mammals and like what a
remarkable thing we are but I want to
know more about the evolutionary
development of the placenta now well I
think that's a good bit of homework for
you Hank I want you to come back next
week having prepared your Mars news in
advance and also with more information
about placental mammals
okay I'm on it we're all trying to reach
harder into a brighter future and that
is going to be your contribution Hank
this question comes from Joshua who
writes dear John and Hank my last name
is a problem it was probably low land
originally but after my ancestors came
to America it was changed to Willie hand
well the hand is not a great last name
especially since my family has quite
small hairless entirely unwilling hands
and since we changed it from our
original actual surname the new one has
no meaning I was wondering if you could
make a more badass meaning in history
from my family name than the real it
used to be Wolin dand then changed when
we ventured to America best Joshua Ryan
wooly hand first off you've got the best
middle name house and secondly I think
that it is I think that's I think that's
cool I mean I like as long as you can
move past it and be like this is weird
this is a weird thing that I got that's
part of me I think it's I think it's
good to have weirdnesses no he's not
he's not looking to change the weirdness
he's looking for an opportunity to have
a better backstory and I think that
that's easy I think you say like my
great grandparents had extremely wooly
hands like not like hairy hands their
hands were literally made out of wool my
great-grandparents were wool workers who
had a magical encounter with wool that
resulted in them having hands made of
sheep's wool and then you just people
people won't ask any questions after
that I promise no maybe maybe his
great-grandparents were in an accident
they were they were they were in the
Arctic and they were digging for gold
and they came across a fully frozen
wooly mammoth and correct and and then
there was but also there was a bunch of
weird raw plutonium that probably came
from a spaceship and it mutated their
hands not into wooly hands but into
woolly mammoth hands and so they had
like woolly mammoth hooves for hands and
then their friends would call them Willy
hands and then that that stuff
but it wasn't genetic it didn't like
stick around so like it wasn't everybody
but they those the two of them did yes
like both the worst superhero you could
possibly be and the worst possible
superhero origin story like what's your
knot power oh as you can see I have
miniature woolly mammoths for hands and
is that useful particularly I'm
certainly very jealous of my friend
Wolverine do have tusks but they're not
like adamantium tusks and I can't like
pick things up so that's a bit of a
drawback I I thought they were good I
thought it's gonna be like a horse with
human hands except it was a person with
with woolly mammoth hands like it just
had hooves but you went to like their
hands are woolly mammoths which I like I
like that better all right let's move on
to another question all right this one
is from Megan who asks dear Hank and
John me and my friends often throw
around obscure questions that will never
be useful I love you and your friends
already Megan recently my friend asks
what would happen if earth lost gravity
for 15 seconds before getting it back I
had absolutely no idea obviously things
would start flying around but that would
but what about things fastened to the
ground like trees and concrete would
they move at all would we go straight up
or just sort of float around would the
rotation of the earth make it seem like
we were travelling diagonally away from
the ground I hope that you can provide
some insight I'm a big fan of the pod
that's interesting I think that maybe
maybe if you were at the equator it
would affect you more you would sort of
float away from the ground a little bit
well and if you have 15 seconds of
floating away from the ground when the
gravity does return it could be a pretty
significant impact I don't think that
nah I don't think so I don't think that
you would rise that far enough off the
ground for it to be a big deal in 15
seconds but I could be wrong what if I
happen to be like jumping to rebound a
basketball in the moment that that
gravity was a radius that that could be
a bigger problem for you 15 seconds of
like the speed you're going at the
moment you jump could be enough to break
a leg especially if you were at the
equator and had the extra
effect of of that but I'd have to do
math man and I as I said earlier I did
not prepare for this podcast as I
previously have by doing wouldn't wait
wait wait wait good scientist wouldn't
not having gravity be a big problem in
read the Earth's rotation like wouldn't
the earth continue to wrote like I mean
is gravity not existing in the entire
universe or only right right on earth I
guess is the first question yeah well I
mean if it's if it was the entire earth
we would float a little bit away from
the Sun for a bit but then then it would
just like we just have a slightly larger
orbit I don't think that it would break
the earth I'm a little worried about
what would happen to the atmosphere
mm-hmm
we might lose a fair like like a bit of
the atmosphere in that moment it would
get farther far enough away that it
would then be blown away by the cosmic
winds from the Sun but I don't I don't
know I don't know how much I mean I
think like it seems to me like this this
is a question that requires basically a
short book to answer like like a good
xkcd what-if exploration and I'm like I
think that it I think we might be
surprised by like for example if you
were close to the Arctic you like would
float away much less than if you were
close to the equator and so like it
might be that people on the equator
actually get much more seriously hurt
than people who are closer to closer to
the poles and that would that's that's
an interesting effect but I'm pretty
sure that would pretty but I thought I
don't think that it would be a huge
effect it might it might be like MIT
like so minuscule that you would barely
even notice so the short answer is that
Hank doesn't know but he's willing to
hazard a guess because that's kind of
that that's sort of how we both built
our careers we have a new question this
one comes from Dahlia who writes Dear
John and Hank
as a conservative who's followed much of
your content for several years you might
even call me a nerdfighter it concerns
me that so much of your audience is not
being exposed to conservative or non
liberal ideas it's very easy to create a
bubble around oneself on the internet so
that you only see political ideas that
align with yours one of the reasons I
watch your channel and listen to your
Podcast so I can understand the beliefs
of many liberals in doing this I've come
to the conclusion that nerdfighteria is
very much an echo chamber of leftism as
you're both liberal that I'm I'm really
really not uh-huh
but I mean I guess I yeah I I guess as
the Republican Party has moved in my
opinion a lot to the right in the last
12 to 15 years maybe I have I feel like
I've stayed the same anyway your comment
sections are dominated Amin ated by
those with liberal views as well and it
seems like your podcast guests tend to
align with your ideologies too although
diverse in terms of race sexuality and
Nationality nerdfighteria seems to lack
the most important kind of diversity
diversity of ideas does that concern you
well it's interesting that that that's
that if that's the most important type
of diversity I mean I think that part of
having diversity of age and diversity of
gender and where you're from like that
results in a diversity of ideas I hope
and I also I think I honestly don't know
what to do about that like meleave these
things I think that it is important that
we recognize that global warming exists
and deal with it because I think that
it's going to be a huge challenge that
we faced in the next 50 100 years I like
I am certain that we need to respect the
rights of people who you know like are
in love with people of their same sex
like like like there's no reason why you
shouldn't be allowed to get married
because you happen to love someone who
has the same sex organs as you like I
just I believe these things and I and
I'm pretty dang sure I'm right so I
don't know what to do I don't know what
to do about that right I mean I I work
really hard to listen to voices that I
disagree with in my like in my life and
in my reading and
and what I look at but I I think one of
the challenges is that it's really
really hard right now to empathize
across the aisle because I think a lot
of people feel like especially the you
know putting aside putting aside the
specific issues the approach to the
issues that's being seen in the Trump
administration is worrying to a lot of
people and it's really really hard to
take the responses to that seriously
like the executive order on immigration
and refugees for instance it's just not
it's just not a good document like it's
not well written it's self contradictory
it wasn't it wasn't and in some cases
still isn't clear what the law now is it
does appear that in at least two places
the executive order violated existing
law which isn't possible
like which isn't supposed to be possible
and is only possible because the
government the parts of the government
that are supposed to review that law
didn't have a chance to review it before
it was released and so it's just I I am
the answer to your question Dalia is
that I am deeply concerned that
nerdfighteria is an echo chamber and
that the entire social Internet is an
echo chamber and that nothing that gets
said on the social Internet does
anything to change anyone's views
because everyone has already decided
what they believe in an incontrovertible
way I am very concerned about that in my
own life and I'm very concerned about it
in nerdfighteria and I'm very concerned
about it on the Internet in general but
I also agree with Hank that I'm I'm sure
that global warming exists and I'm sure
that it's one of the biggest challenges
faced by the world and I'm sure that if
we pull out of the Paris climate Accord
it's a catastrophe for the world and and
I I don't know what to do about the fact
that I'm sure about those things but I'm
yeah I'm making sure that I'm right and
doesn't think that makes it hard right
now what I have tried to do is make it
about the things that I believe in care
about but not about the people who
oppose me
and so I don't want to make content
that's like here is what the idiots on
the other side are saying aren't they
idiots and I don't think we'd do that
right I ought to do that I do it
sometimes on Twitter but I don't they
try not to do it on vlogbrothers yeah me
too I try not to do it outside of
Twitter but I and I hate that I dine on
Twitter and so I like that that is that
is a way that like it's not I understand
that it's not a diversity of ideas but
hopefully it's not exclusionary to the
ideas because it's not like I'm like I
think that it's so easy to take the most
extreme voice and say look at what the
other side is saying they're literal
Nazis and like some of them are but most
of them aren't and and so that that
really tears everything apart and and
and it makes it impossible to have
useful conversations and it makes it
impossible to like it makes it
worryingly difficult to have a country
together yeah especially because like
like like once you have sort of an idea
ideology put in place like if all you
ever hear is the most extreme stories
from the other side then it does seem
like you're fighting a battle against
evil and hopefully like I don't want to
feel like I'm fighting a battle against
evil I want to feel like I'm having a
argument about how to correctly proceed
and and make the world better for the
most possible people though also I think
there's there's well but not everybody
agrees that that kind of utilitarianism
is even the goal I mean I I think it's
it what I find interesting is that I'm
able to have most of my closest friends
in real life are I I guess would
probably be considered conservatives or
most most often vote for Republican
candidates for state and national office
and I'm able to talk to them about
politics a lot it's been hard the last
five months
X months but it's not it hasn't been
impossible for the vast majority of that
of that time even though like you know I
think the Republican Party has changed a
lot in very disturbing ways in the last
15 years now like look there's you know
there's always been there's always been
problems with both political parties in
the u.s. I don't want to you know I
don't want to make it sound one way or
the other but point being unable to have
those conversations in real life I'm
able to like seek common ground and find
it and at least have an it figure out
what we disagree about and understand
what we disagree about and not think
that the other person is evil or an
idiot and I really do struggle with that
online and I really I I feel like a lot
of times online the way people talk to
people and I don't exclude myself from
this imagines that those you disagree
with our idiots and and I I do think a
lot of times like I really believe that
in the Republican Party right now there
are a lot of people who are saying that
certain people do not deserve the full
rights of equal protection under the law
I think that's what voting the voting
restrictions amount to I think that's
what the refuge the refugee and
immigration ban amounts to especially
when it seemed until you know late in
the game that it was going to be applied
to legal permanent residents of the
United States I think a and like those
are big big problems to me because I
think equal protection under the law is
the foundational idea of American
democracy so it it's really hard to have
a calm conversation about that because
it scares the crap out of me and because
I also feel like I have to stick up for
the people who are being systematically
disenfranchised in this conversation
yeah anyway we don't know and also I
really quickly want to note one other
thing which is that while answering this
question Dalia I changed her name to
Delia and now is that my bad I'm sorry
as if things weren't bad enough I did I
went and did that but thank you for
listening to this podcast and thank you
also for you know for trying to keep the
lines of communication open because I it
has never been harder than it is now and
we really appreciate it and we want to
try to do the same yeah and and I
apologize for the moments in which we
dehumanize people who disagree with us
it's too easy these days and and I want
to endeavour to try to not do that as
much this question is from Fletcher who
asks dear Hank and John I'm trans and
I'm about to embark upon the legal
process of changing my name I've already
cited on Fletcher as my first name but
I'm feeling conflicted when it comes to
my middle name on one hand my father it
was called James and I know it would
make him happy to choose it he put so
much effort into choosing my birth name
which I now am no longer responding to
what's more I quite like the name James
so I wouldn't be forcing myself so I
wouldn't be forcing myself to have a
middle name that I despise for all
eternity on the other hand the name
Balthazar is cool as heck and it would
make my initials FBI I would like your
inputs on whether I should choose a
normal sentimental name or a cool name
that would be a talking point best
wishes Fletcher
or possibly but Fletcher Balthazar or
Fletcher James yeah I mean I think the
solution here is pretty obvious Hank you
want to just say it on three or do you
like try to hash this one out I've aimed
deeply disagree with you on this one
John but you go let's do it on three
okay one two three
James what was I thinking of course
Brian
I mean look that's right it's obviously
Ryan there's only one way forward here
you're in a moment of uncertainty that's
the kind of moment that only Ryan can
solve I do like I do like this thought
process that I'm I'm glad you're
thinking of it and trying to be
inclusive a little bit think Balthazar
might be a mistake
yeah I mean I like I really like I love
names that honor important family
members but I love the name Ryan even
more what a terrible mistake Hank we
both made naming our children something
other than Ryan and I could have two
kids name
and how cool would that be it would be
like hey my name is Ryan this is my
sister Ryan or my name is Ryan this is
my brother Ryan which Alice would never
say all she would actually say is my
name is Ryan give me water where's my
water daddy I like ice in it a little a
little bit demand e she's three but yeah
she's a little bit too Mandy the other
day
the other day she said daddy daddy daddy
she that's how she says daddy yeah daddy
I want ice in it and I was like Alice
there's ice there is ice look at that
like you can literally see daddy I want
it all ice and I was like no you don't
you can't drink it if it's all ice ah
this podcast is brought to you by all
ice all ice the delicious refreshment of
the future only Alice green truly
understand the nature of the wonderful
beverage that is all ice you know what I
just realized all ice is very very
similar to Alice's actual name that's
true it's true in a way we're all ice so
maybe I shouldn't complain today's
podcast is also brought to you by people
who kiss like dying fish just like dying
fish not recommended and also this
podcast is brought to you by all 10
types of spoons all 10 types of spoons
necessary for the life of a true
gentleman and lastly this podcast is
brought to you by gravity gravity you
know I think we could live without it
for 15 seconds do you think well I mean
I the thing is like Hank and I both know
an equal amount about that question
which is nothing but hank is able to
talk as if he does know something about
it so true that's true I I just typed in
15 seconds without gravity into Google
and I didn't find anything useful well
that's good but actually that's probably
good news yeah what I do want to say is
just just in general be very careful
about when you jump because you never
know when gravity's gonna turn off and
you're just gonna go
flying away that wouldn't be a bad way
to go in the scheme of things Hank this
question comes from an anonymous short
spouse I'm not sure why this person
didn't want to be identified but they
didn't and will respect that so
hello Green brothers my husband's
birthday is coming up and he is also
tall we like a lot of the shirts on
dftba.com but they are not made for tall
people how do you get tall person shirts
can i buy tall person shirts from you
best wishes short spouse so first off
I'm 6 1 and those shirts fit me
fantastically in fact I only wear shirts
from dftba.com your number one source
for shirts on the internet I mean I'm
wearing one right now I wear them all
the time and and I also am one inch
taller than John and I'm also 61 so I
you know you always say that yeah I I
have to stop you right there and I do
not like to stop you in the middle of a
commercial for dftba.com your number one
source for Internet merchandise but I
have to stop you right there because I
you've gotten into my head so much about
this you being one inch taller than me
and you being six one thing that like
I've started to think that maybe I'm
only six feet tall and so I went to get
when I was doing onto stuff for 100 days
like I had to get a cardiac stress test
and get weighed and get my height done
and everything and like all these EKGs
and whatnot
they measured my height and they said I
was like 6 1 or like a 1/4 inch less
than 6 1 so I think that either we are
the same height and you are just
creating some kind of like visual thing
that makes you look an inch taller than
me like you've just like made like it
you're like gaslighting me about what
I'm actually seeing or alternately you
are actually you've been 6 - this whole
time oh my god it's crazy to think that
I might be 6 - that sounds so tall to me
well anyway point being - like the
shirts still fit they do fit me and I'm
6 - but if I mean if he's like 6 8 I
understand that that might like that
might cause like midriff problems yeah
but that's the solution you've actually
just answered the question right just go
with the
yeah your husband needs to bear his
midriff to the world like he faces a
stark choice don't wear dftba.com
t-shirts or rock the bare midriff and I
think you know option B is
overwhelmingly the best choice you know
John I've been working with a lot of
onesies these days and yeah there's a
nice thing about about wearing a onesie
so like the onesie a baby onesie it can
be like a long-sleeved shirt and then it
wraps around onto the diaper and buttons
and and then you can put pants on over
that so the legs are still totally out
and it's just like this little thing
that buttons under the crotch and the
legs are out and you put pants on but
then like the shirt never comes untucked
because it's connected like it's it's
around like why isn't that an adult
thing what like can't I have like a nice
button-down shirt that then like wraps
around underneath my underwear area and
then like it's some way fastens so that
it never has any chance of ever coming
like never getting loosened to jostle
doubt of my talk of my pants taco I
don't know whether to treat your
question seriously why not but I will
say that I think the history of fashion
is fascinating but if you're being
serious it's because it takes too long
to pee I think you're right you're a
tiny baby child you have somebody who
changes your diapers for you and so it
doesn't matter that you're wearing your
Z right okay in fact the exact moment at
which children stop wearing onesies in
my experience is when they stop wearing
diapers interesting okay I'm in I'm in
like I'm just like I feel like I'm just
ahead of you on this one particular
curve like you're smarter than me and
almost everything but I know just a
little bit more about children now well
that's yes definitely that is the case
I've got another question John it's
really important I want to make sure we
get to it before we get to the
all-important news from Mars and AFC
Wimbledon it's from Jillian who asks
dear Hank and John I just bought a new
jigsaw puzzle when
open the box some of the pieces were
already put together hmm am i morally
obliged to break up the pieces and start
from scratch
is it cheating if I don't can you cheat
on a jigsaw puzzle if you're the only
one puzzling advice on this pressing
issue would be greatly appreciated kind
regards Jillian Jillian the only person
you're cheating is yourself you know
what this make you're gonna be cheating
yourself out of the opportunity to build
that entire jigsaw puzzle from scratch
or there is a person this is true at the
jigsaw puzzle Factory who takes the
jigsaw puzzle that has been printed out
on a piece of cardboard and stamped with
that jigsaw puzzle stamp breaking it
into a bunch of pieces who then takes
that breaks it all up very carefully as
to make sure to not lose any pieces and
puts it in the bag and then puts that
bag in a box and that person sometimes
they leave a few pieces put together and
there may be that person is thinking to
themselves I've done a little favor for
my friend the purchaser of my jigsaw
puzzle so that they will not have to put
together all they'll see this these
three pieces this five pieces maybe that
were left together I did that for them
so they would have a good starting point
maybe I like it
maybe I love it I love it I agree you
should let them be because of the person
and/or machine that did that for you I
have no idea if it's a machine or a
person and I would like to mean I'm
gonna bet at this point it's a machine
there's only about four jobs that have
not been automated yet hank real quickly
we need to get to some corrections we
had some some really important
Corrections from last week's pod Ben
wrote in for instance to say
respectfully in a recent podcast Hank
stated you can't see Mars from Mars but
to quote lay miserable the look down
that is good it's real good and I I did
have that same I saw that correction and
was like yes very good I love it
Ben also wanted said PS feel free to
shout out my amazing girlfriend jazz I
don't know if that's the same jazz who's
just and Claire who played Angela in the
Paper Towns movie but it's spelled
wait so maybe I hope so if it is just
assuming jazz you're awesome if it isn't
I'm sure you're also awesome just second
correction real quickly from Anissa
she wrote in to say Dear John and Hank I
am a former space physics major while I
completely understand your desire to
study the physics of space that is not
actually the topic which space physics
refers to space physics is has more to
do with atmospheric physics and
satellite stuff the type of physics that
you are probably thinking of is
astronomy and astrophysics satellites
not spaceships
Anisa current computational mathematics
major I mean Anisa I'm gonna level with
you I did not understand any of the
words in that correction but I did my
best to read them in order so that you
could be technically correct it's
corrected now and I'll be honest with
you I was watching a how it's made video
on puzzles and can confirm that it is
the machine who has done you the favor
not a human being I'll put the link to
this video in the patreon description of
the video
boy that was definitely done by a
machine yeah I kind of figured Hank
what's the news from Mars that you
looked up twelve minutes ago alright
I'll just tell you the news from AFC
Wimbledon Hank so this is a little
confusing but in soccer in England you
can only sign new players during certain
periods
there's the summer transfer window which
ends on August 31st and then there's the
January transfer window which ends on
January 31st and AFC Wimbledon
traditionally don't do a lot of business
in the January transfer window because
that's kind of it's sort of for like
richer clubs plus AFC Wimbledon is in
the middle of the table and it's not
clear you know what what they have to to
fight for at this point you know I mean
obviously the job is to stay up and it
looks likely that they will stay up
although actually they're down in 13th
now so maybe maybe there's still a
little bit of work to do only ten points
clear the drop point being on the
transfer deadline day AFC Wimbledon did
sign a new player a 30 year old player
named Tom Soares
soare so so rests I don't nobody knows
how to pronounce his name it's like
Gillingham but the point is he is now
playing for AFC Wimbledon and knee
largely the beloved manager of AFC
Wimbledon said the following about him
tom is very powerful has good aerial
ability and I think he is in his prime
now and I just wanted to say that is
what I would like um to be known for I
wish that someone would say that
sentence about me John is very powerful
has good aerial ability and I think he
is in his prime now I just want someone
to say that I'm in my prime now anyway
congratulations Tom on becoming a member
of AFC Wimbledon and leaving your former
club Barry or possibly brewery nobody
knows how to say town names in England
okay what's the news from Mars well
first I wanted to say you got to be
careful about that aerial ability jump
because you never know when gravity's
gonna turn off but additionally let's
just let's say that Mark Kelly you know
who Mark Kelly is right John yeah
astronaut yeah good job the astronaut
that's been a year in space twin brother
Scott Kelly so that they could have like
a twin experiment with space stuff Mark
Kelly has released a editorial talking
about why he would he says that we
should get to Mars the United States
needs to have people on Mars by 2033 for
the good of the nation now I have one
big problem with this John yeah it's
five years too late no I think it's the
perfect timing definitely five years too
late he gives he gives three main
reasons for why we should get to Mars by
2033 the first being I'm gonna go in
reverse order he says that the United
States cannot lose its dominance in
space I don't know what that means I
don't really feel like it's a great
reason I know who needs to dominate
Speight space it's a really big it's a
big old place and I don't feel like
anybody can dominate it really it's
almost all of the places that is the
vast majority of places positionally
focusing on Earth is a vanishingly small
portion of the universe just very yes it
is the least of the places focusing on a
Mars mission additionally would
jumpstart our economy which I do think
would be
and I think we would learn a lot about
our capabilities as a nation and as a
technical species by focusing on this
but lastly the just increasing chance
that we are going to find alien life and
Mars is the easiest place to find it it
might not be the most likely place to
find it probably one of the water moons
of Jupiter or Saturn would be a more
likely place to find it just because
there's so much water but the the the
it's easy much easier to get to Mars
much easier to get to the watery parts
if there are watery parts and just what
we could learn about the universe by
discovering life for a second time yeah
no I agree I think that would be really
really cool I mean and I mean is a
manned mission to Mars the only way to
get to discover life no but it is so
much easier it's so much like the humans
are Vellore versatile and and able to do
things that robots can't do you know
curiosity hasn't even designed really to
look for life and additionally like
microscopic life is difficult to parse
out what's alive and what isn't like
that like even viruses were kind of like
I don't know does that count and and if
it's very different from what life looks
like on earth it's not based on the same
chemistry if it's not based on like
certainly if it isn't based in the same
biology now it might be based in the
same biology
if life spread from Mars to earth or
from Earth to Mars and that would also
be a very interesting thing to discover
that that's possible and a thing that
happened but but it could be based an
entirely different biology like
different methods for storing genetic
information or like no genetic
information at all or who knows who
knows it could be much more like what
life was on earth when it first formed
which of course we don't even know what
that was but but understanding the
chemistry of that is going to be really
difficult to get to the bottom of
this really makes it a lot easier to
have people who are working in the field
as it were yeah and I have to say Hank I
think that just getting all of our ducks
in a row and just getting human capacity
to the place where we need it to be and
just there's I I think it makes great
sense to just say 2033 that's the goal
we're gonna focus on that date we're not
gonna consider any dates sooner than
that there might be delays you never
know but we're gonna plan for 2033 maybe
it'll be twenty thirty five twenty
thirty seven maybe things will get done
really fast it'll be twenty thirty one
maybe it'll be twenty twenty-nine you
know I I would even if like if the pace
of innovation you know suddenly jump
starts and we end up on Mars in 2029 I
would say that wouldn't be such a bad
outcome oh good
the important thing is that it's dear
Hank and John now and it's gonna be dear
Hank and John in 2027 and we're gonna
hold on to that for a for at least ten
years I'm proud of that well I mean what
do you mean you're proud of that you you
just you named our podcast when we
started because you were the person
filling out the iTunes info yeah what
what is there to be proud of you know
what else I did though John
you know what else I did I made a bet
that required the outcome of the bet to
not change until the bet date was
reached which means I have secured the
podcast name at dear Hank and John for
10 years which is if I do say so myself
a masterful piece of deal-making I mean
some people would say that you should
write a book called the art of the deal
I mused on the topic of how to make sure
that a podcast has your name first for
the whole decade I mean I'm really
something else John I gotta say that you
are you are there's no question about
that Hank green : something else alright
John what did we learn today well we
learned that Hank doesn't actually know
what would happen if gravity stops on
earth for 15 seconds but he pretended to
but then eventually he had to
acknowledge that he didn't
oh yeah which is you know really most of
the conversations I have these days we
also learned that shoot we also learned
that if you have the opportunity to
change your middle name you should
probably go it's hard to be trying hard
to be tryin we learned that belly
buttons are definitely scars and that
when they're startup they smell a little
bit funky but not bad you can tell the
difference they can double have a
difference in if they smell bad you
should go see a doctor and finally
finally we learned that the very worst
superhero with the very worst origin
story is grandpa and grandma Willy
mammoth hands Oh
Hank thank you for popping with me if
you want to email us please email us
your questions at Hank and John at
gmail.com you can also use the hashtag
dear Hank and John on Twitter where I'm
Hank green and no pepper
I'm not handcream I'm John Green and
Hank is Hank green I'm having a crisis
of self Hank
dear Hank and John is produced by
rosianna halse rojas and sheridan Gibson
our editors Nicholas Jenkins Victoria
ponch owners are head of community and
communications our music is by the great
gunnarolla thank you again for listening
and as we say in our hometown don't
forget to be awesome
[Music]
you